the select committee investigating the
january 6 attack will hold the first in
a series of public hearings following a
nearly year-long investigation u.s
capitol police officer carolyn edwards
who was injured that day will testify as
well as documentary filmmaker nick quest
did he'll share his story he was filming
far-right extremist groups on january
6th and in addition to that we hear this
morning have new audio of republican
house minority leader kevin mccarthy it
was recorded just days after the assault
so let's go now to congressional
correspondent scott mcfarland who has
that audio for us and to learn more
about what the committee will be
focusing on tonight before we get to it
scott good morning again hey tony good
morning we're going to hear the words
conspiracy and coordination a lot
tonight like when did the coordination
begin we know where it ended and the
best perspective to show you is the west
front of the capitol where a crowd of
thousands use their size and their
magnitude coordinating a breach of the
police lines you'll hear the name
oathkeepers a lot tonight the far right
group accused of conspiracy and of using
this choreographed military stack
formation to get past the police lines
and get past the doors we'll also hear
the name proud boys a lot tonight
another accused conspiracy group another
far-right group accused of leading
people in this mob
into the capitol and we'll see images
like this talk about coordination in the
west front tunnel a coordinated medieval
claustrophobic fight by rioters against
police but in a broader sense we're
going to figure out i'm going to hear
what gave rise
to this seminal american moment like
this one where in nancy pelosi's office
suite we have people walking the halls
after speaker pelosi was evacuated
elsewhere off the senate chamber you'll
recall this
the vice president of the united states
evacuated out the back door down a
staircase to an evacuation site and then
just 30 minutes later
people
inside the capitol in that same
staircase banging on doors the question
is tony what gave rise what gave rise to
this moment
yeah that is the question there's gonna
be a lot of focus on that today and
speaking of questions we've got some
questions for you yeah yeah so scott let
me ask you it's vlad uh so there's some
new obvious audio obtained by cbs news
from the authors of this will not pass
and it reveals the conversations that
republican lawmakers were having amongst
themselves in the days after the attack
including this clip from minority leader
kevin mccarthy i want to play that for
our viewers
we cannot just sweep this under the rug
we need to know why it happened who did
it and people need to be held
accountable for it and i'm committed to
make sure that happens
all right so scott how do we get from
that to where we are now with this
largely partisan investigation it's a
long journey let's show you where it
started on january 6th at about 2pm
you'll recall this image from inside the
house chamber there were some republican
members of the house who helped
barricade this door to keep the rioters
out who helped police prepare for that
moment at the same time there were some
republicans on the upper level of the
chamber hiding beneath chairs
as a group tried to break open those
windows and get inside in the time since
we've heard republicans call the
committee investigating this
illegitimate because it's composed of
members exclusively chosen
by speaker nancy pelosi they've called
it a witch hunt one republican member
called what happened that day
a typical tourist visit they'll continue
to criticize the committee with a press
conference later today
yeah it's one thing to be in the midst
of it something else when
you have some time to think about an
incredible flip-flop but scott i have to
ask you you've been covering this more
perhaps more than anyone else out there
what are you going to be looking for
michelle are we going to get answers
about the three hours
what was happening and what was not
happening at the white house during the
three hours in which
medieval fighting was happening here at
the capitol as police were trying to
stop a crowd as police were trying to
get control of the capitol complex the
committee has been clear they want to
know who was in president trump's ear
what was he saying what was he hearing
in the hours as the riot occurred and
before the capital was breached
interesting a lot of questions hopefully
will be answered scott thank you so much